okay first of all emma are you excited
to find out glenn close's reaction to
the movie
oh lord um
yeah yes
are you nervous at all no no
no i don't yeah i mean she's the she's
the greatest
to ever do it so yeah whatever she feels
is i
fully respect did you get to talk to her
at all
like just preparing for this role a
little bit we talked about it a little
bit and um
it was pretty early on in the process
when we still were kind of didn't know
you know what was going to be happening
with the movie so but she's
she's amazing and i'm a huge admirer of
hers
obviously yeah um obviously as a huge
animal lover cruella is a villain
um in this film is there any attempt
to make her likeable
what do you guys think the fact that you
see
where she comes from kind of
explains a lot about her
personality you know you didn't really
get to see that before but
the fact that she comes from quite a
harsh place yeah explains
a lot of her behaviors so yeah
i think that's that's what that is yeah
was it a lot of fun on set with all the
dogs and puppies did you guys just want
to like take them home
i mean it was it was a really fun
contagious sort of atmosphere
with the animals there but at the same
time they're there to do a job too like
it'd be funny i'd be like
oh well hello how are you and the
trainer's like we're working right now
yeah it's true they're there for a
purpose a dog's purpose
and i i did my best to contain my uh my
youthful enthusiasm
if they really don't like it you do the
dog voice with them because it gets them
a little bit riled up you know when
you're like hi
what's going on that kind of thing yeah
uh joel and paul you know what was emma
like off
camera was she a method actor or did she
turn it off
or was she cruel uh i i emma stone off
camera
is uh exactly who you hope she is yeah
really really humble and generous and
funny
and emma thompson's kind of the same way
where like you just kind of want to hang
out with them
uh it was it was a lot of fun yeah
um best part or maybe the highlight of
making this film for all of you
if you could pick one thing
um all the other people who are doing it
like all of them
yeah so the same way the people the
people were what made it
uh not just fun but but bearable
yeah and i would my answer would just be
uh making those disney dollars you know
what i mean
paul's always like it's just paycheck
everyone it's just me
i'm always looking for the precipitation
i'm always trying to make it rain
thank you great baby yes yes actually
wipes his brow with dollar bills
i'm sorry i'm sorry the people is what i
meant to say
um emma for you just the transformation
so many incredible fashion looks
um were all of them comfortable was it
fun for you you know what was that
transformation like
well i mean i don't know fashion and
comfort always go hand in hand a lot of
them weren't the most comfortable things
but they were so much fun to wear and
there were so many of them
it's it's kind of surreal to think that
you know these
these costumes that took months and
months to make made it into the movie
for like 15 seconds
yeah um but yeah jenny bevin the costume
designer and naughty stacy did the hair
and makeup it all kind of worked
in tandem and i think they did the most
unbelievable job
you